أنا مواطن نيجيري حر في نيجيريا،
ليس لديك حقك، لذلك ظللت
أفكر فيما يجب أن أفعله
[موسيقى]
كنت سأصبح بطلاً ثم
فجأة وجدت نفسي هنا في البرازيل
في إسكريتو سانتوس فيكتوريا  لذلك عندما
جاءت الشرطة الفيدرالية لم أكن أعرف، ولا
أعرف حتى أين كنت
[موسيقى]
أوه
لقد كانت تجربة مروعة بالنسبة لي، لقد كنت
أول مرة لم أحاول ذلك
من قبل ولكن لأنه  لقد اتخذت قراري بالفعل
بترك
بعض الشجاعة، كما تعلمون، إذًا
لم يكن الأمر سهلاً، كما تعلمون،
أهتز قليلاً، كنت خائفًا للغاية وكنت
سعيدًا بسماع "الأخوة"
[موسيقى]
كنت شخصًا يجلس على
الكتلة في كتلة السفينة  لذلك
جاءوا وكان لديهم هل تعرف أين أنت
قلت لا وقالوا هذه
البرازيل كان أول شيء
قالوا هذه هي البرازيل أقول واو هذه
البرازيل لقد وصلت إلى البرازيل أنا سعيد